je crois toujours à la vertu on a vécu
des choses des films très bien fait a
fait des débuts de films bien fait et
j'ai essayé avec les avec mes amis
mettent en scène de faire des belles
choses des choses bien faites aussi que
ce sont les comiques ou dramatiques et
ça marche comme un bon plat un bon plan
cuisineraient bien cuisiner toujours bon
je crois parce qu'il faut aussi dire une
chose est ce si votre modestie vous
empêche évidemment dans le faire c'est
que tous ces films ont louis de funès
pour interprètes
est ce que vous attendiez à ce succès
qui était le vôtre
ah non pas du tout j'ai préféré ivan
klasnic j'aurais effrayer est ce que
vous avez senti cette espèce de monter
de votre succès si vous voulez vous fait
penser à ces bons coureurs cyclistes
vous savez dans le tour de france qui
participe à tous les tours de france qui
sont pas des lanternes rouges mais qui
sont 24e 25e puis un jour il passe 15e
ou 14e audit yalaoui petit c'est pas mal
et on croit que ça s'arrête là qu'un
jour ils sont premiers et vous êtes
premier tout le temps est ce que vous
avez eu conscience de cette évolution
progressivement
oui j'ai gelé fait un peu avant moi je
les juge obtenue involontairement parce
que j'ai tout ça je peux le dire ça me
flatte et j'ai toujours mis de essayé de
mettre le maximum de qualité dans ce que
je faisais maxime une trouvaille de
choses et ça m'a occasionné cette montée
insensible et puis alors après quand
j'ai dit oui au fait là ça m'a effrayée
mais je ne cherchais pas aller là où je
cherchais à bien faire et peut-être que
je tombe dans une période où y'a pas
beaucoup de gens qui songent a bien fait
rire de lancement ensuite c'est pour ça
je crois aussi parce que je suis premier
tour de france dans cette ossature de
son sachet produit parce que moi je
crois que normalement je devrais être un
bon second et puis y'a pas de premier
set chance